One of the best achievements of our show is
the combination between what’s real and
what’s not. That’s what distinguishes
our show from a lot of things, because we
try not to separate from reality.
If everything was special effects, we would
be on a set right now, instead of
the meditarrean coast of Spain. We need this
on our skin, the sun, the old castles built
by the Moors. I have Spanish dust between
my fingers right now. You can’t get that
on a set.
Spain is so massive. Its locations, its views.
We could do a kind of itinerant show this
year. We had so many new worlds to visit,
we went from the north side of Spain to the
south.
We had five different locations in five different
cities. In the north, a little more green.
In the south, a little more desert. The Dothraki
we had in Spain were great.
We started the trip in Girona. We were there
for two weeks, in the city centre. Because
Girona is a nice city, a really beautiful
city.
Yeah, we went to Girona. It’s a beautiful
medieval city. A perfect setting for Game
of Thrones.
From Girona we traveled west many kilometers
to Bardenas Reales, a desert and mountainous
In the show we see beautiful deserts. It was
very funny, incredible. The last scene was
From there we went to Castillo de Zafra, in
the middle of nowhere, in a place called the
Spanish Siberia, because it’s one of the
coldest places on Spain.
The location was absolutely unreal. It looked
like a set. From that place you could see
these huge plains, like the ones in Africa.
It was the most incredible place that I could
From there we went to Peñíscola. It’s
an old coastal town. A rocky town located
in the middle of the Mediterranean Sea. After
Peñíscola, we moved here, the last place
of the five in which we will work. But it’s
not the last location, because we’re going
to film in Almería, where we are right now.
We
have another five different locations.
I lost track of so many different locations.
But each sequence of GOT has a couple of very
stunning moments. And being here, on the outskirts
of Almería has been for me one of these shocking
It’s been good coming back here. I never
lose that thrill as an actor. I had it in
a lot of movies. But in this show the level
is exceptional. What the people built. The
passion with which they work. And we
have very committed extras.
Last year, the level of extras we had here
in Spain was amazing. This year happened again.
I never met more hard-working people, happy
about being there. They infect everyone on
set. It’s a display of happiness, trust
and security. It was a joy.
The show being back to Spain is
very important for this country. Given the
dimensions of GOT, everyone loves it, the
people worked very excited. Wherever you go,
that’s the way it is. And it’s a pleasure,